[Music]
anybody here like tigers
i like tigers i love tigers top three
favorite animal right so what are the
other two yeah i want to hear this i
like chimpanzees the most palsies
and then my second favorite is dolphins
oh
they're sick as [ __ ]
i like that funny and they're funny
hated animals oh yeah you got the top
three hated animals regular whales
because i don't like the name and
branding
it's vital what about orcas
but the branding and the names oh i see
i like freewheeling i don't like what
they do to see world trainers because i
think that those are good people yeah
they're just doing their job just doing
their job
yeah wow it's called whitefish the
documentary is every favorite second
least favorite animal you said oh dude
emus because i had an emu bite me in the
arm one time i punched him in the
[ __ ] head you punched an emu in the
head all right bite your arm it was
retaliation
protection no i had a watch on and my
uncle was an emu farmer and um yeah the
emu was like coming up to me and then i
was like oh [ __ ] and they're [ __ ]
huge right and i was like 12 years old
and he he like bit me on the arm and i
like went pop like that and he just go
like oh my god
is he right that's joe
not to be confused with an ostrich
they're smaller evens are big [ __ ]
dudes they're big but they're smaller
yeah they're smaller
i think about the way that like giraffes
fight with their with their necks and
stuff they're like hitting each other
but then they have so much neck that
it's like
it's finding its way to be strong
holographic everyday exactly
my number three least favorite animal
yeah oh man apparently it's white
let's go
[Laughter]
oh i didn't know i ran into my ex-wife
exhibit
oh my god this is like
jesus
the jerry lewis
oh all right so uh okay i actually just
take a breath for a second because this
is actually tragic
why'd you stand up like that
he [ __ ] was the one who brought on
the stand up dude
i think he's a terrible host shut up
[Laughter]
critically endangered tiger
fatally shot at a florida zoo after a
biting man's arm good riddance very
similar to your story with the emu jesus
always good riddance i i'm we're
supposed to be the side be on the other
side yay tiger good british jesus but no
yates the tiger died i don't know which
side of history i want to be on yet
we got to hear more information first
before we pick we want to make a hot
take and then we want to figure it out
later
[Laughter]
give us one more reaction we'll see what
happens i'm trying to find clips that
people can take to cancel us there you
go there and then we can apologize yeah
yeah out of context yeah so did he have
to shoot the tiger to get him to stop
biting him or did he get bit come back
later and just get him with the game
yeah oh jesus as if he escaped the first
bite right was he [ __ ] around with
the tiger okay it's also the policy
right if an animal bites a human being
you just got to put them down so that it
doesn't have like a technically a taste
for blood hey dude
we need to focus more on animal
rehabilitation and not punishment that's
true i agree so true true and who was in
whose territory mm-hmm you want to
abolish your death penalty for tigers
yeah yeah because i want to know like if
this guy went into tiger territory and
was like he had a [ __ ] stick and he
was like poking at the cubs well mama
tiger's gonna [ __ ] you up right mm-hmm
that's his fault
can you imagine the [ __ ] poking at a cup
with a stick what kind of human hey
honestly that [ __ ] happened there's some
dumb [ __ ] he's a board human
that every single time he's [ __ ]
you know these zoo [ __ ] stories come
out it's always some dumb [ __ ] yeah from
the human anyway so let's take these
tours trying to take get a [ __ ]
close-up photo there's those dumbass and
[ __ ] or the people like i don't know how
my kid got in the tiger exhibit it's
like
come on man you threw him in there
really be a better parent so authorities
in the us have shot and killed a
critically endangered tiger after it bit
the arm of men who entered an
unauthorized area okay yeah all right
[ __ ] up if you kill the tiger you have
to kill the guy too yup yeah i agree you
gotta kill bob you gotta kill the guy or
else we'll get a taste if you're gonna
you're gonna kill the guy too don't kill
the tiger okay yeah
is to kill the tiger after it hurts a
human being and you have to kill the
tiger then you should kill the guy too
well if you kill the guy then he's no
longer hurting then kill the guy first
or i don't care or don't kill anybody
leave the guy in there the tiger will
just eat him yeah i like that if he
crossed the cage that way
that'll be kind of cool so the idea is
that if the tiger eats a human he wants
to eat humans all the time is that the
idea yeah that's not fair though this is
suspicious because if it's the first
time he's going to eat a human
then doesn't the tiger always want to
eat a human muscle does not have tigers
that's very true
very true i thought that's only what
they do with like wild animals
either way they should just kill this
guy closure this is a zoo enclosure
should they do it for that too and this
is an unauthorized area where there's
been okay what's going to happen with
dolphins never continue it's not just
this is not just a tourist so there's
there maybe is a gray area they should
have a sign that says die at your own
risk yep and then so anytime people
[ __ ] go across and tiger kills it's
like [ __ ] i told you fool yes you saw
the sign yeah
so the man who's in his 20s and worked
for an external cleaning service at the
naples zoo in florida suffered serious
injuries after an eight-year-old malayan
tiger named iko bit him oh was he
cleaning up tiger poop he was working no
no no authorized entry though no not yet
uh-oh preliminary information indicates
that the man was either petting or
feeding the animal both of which are
unauthorized and dangerous activities
unauthorized it added that the third
party cleaning service which the man
worked for is only responsible for
cleaning restrooms and the gift shop not
animal enclosures what are you doing
dude can i ask a question that's just
really might sound [ __ ] up but i swear
to god it's not
it's just one of those
cleaning services
with disabled people are the only oh the
special cleaning service yes uh it
doesn't it doesn't say that no oh
because you could well for the sake of
the story absolutely he was blind he
couldn't hear anything and he had a
lover should die the tigers are bad you
can't pull that stuff off like that
literally
it doesn't have like i literally just
said no and it said for the fun you
[ __ ]
there's something missing
i think he's trying to fool us fullest
dude i thought the guy was count
chocolate
what is this i'm just gonna walk off
guarantee you can't but he knew none of
us would know that so he he didn't count
chocolate oh yeah i could guarantee that
it wasn't the disabled cleaning service
because i have personal experience with
them and if you tell them a rule yes
they will never do they're not
mischievous they will never do it all
right because they're like they have a
specific task if you tell them not to go
there they will not their focus is like
super strong huh
so initial reports indicate that the
tiger grabbed the man's arm and pulled
it into the enclosure after the man
traversed an initial fence berry and put
his arm through the fencing of the tiger
[ __ ] that's some gangster yeah
which happened after the zoo had closed
for the day
prompted deputies to respond to the
scene the first debut to kick the
enclosure and
attempted to get the tiger to release
man's arm from his mouth but the deputy
was eventually quote unquote forced to
shoot the animal i was forced taken to a
hospital
uh and eco's killing has obviously
prompted outrage online with many users
blaming the man for entering a
restricted area it's his fault the
tiger's dead
they shot the tiger for being a tiger
but also what happens to the guy does he
does he serve any sort of like is there
like is all the videos of people [ __ ]
around with the animal enclosures do
they ever get in trouble nothing happens
to him now he has to do is just get an
automatic car because stick shift is out
of the question yeah
why don't they get the trainers who
raised the tiger because i've watched a
lot of these videos on youtube yeah just
walk in the enclosure the tiger runs up
and starts like hugging him and stuff
then he would be obviously distracted
then the guy could make an exit
duh
how many of those videos have you seen
i've seen so many of those videos those
cats they walk up
to like lions they just walk up the line
and say oh he he bottle-fed these lions
and then these [ __ ] lions look like
they're about to eat this guy and then
they start licking them on the face
because they're like daddy yeah yeah
it's like the real tarzan is that the
guy's name
oh yeah yeah
that's the real tarzan that feels
gangster this guy's tight right does he
work at a zoo or something because she
knows all these like always like in
africa and stuff and they're like the
lion's like rushing at him and you're
like what the [ __ ] and then he's like
come here and [ __ ] lion jumps on him
and he's like hugging him and [ __ ] nuts
that's crazy crazy it's like your cat
franklin yeah dude he's the best dude
this was cat every single time we come
home his cat just goes up to uh steve
and just like
literally comes up on time like puts his
[ __ ] paws up on steve and it's like
pick me up pick me up and then [ __ ]
like he picks
and he just climbs up and he just chills
there on his shoulder like a parent ever
it's the [ __ ] cutest [ __ ] i've ever
seen even though steve's yeah i'm hard
dude i'm [ __ ] hard though
like a cat you got a cat parrot like
steve don't deserve this love
he's like frankly you know he calls your
wife an animal
ex-wife ex-wife oh ex-wife sorry that's
right that's right oh yeah
well i mean he said some other stuff
about nikki dude that's true i used to
just come in with a fish and i'd throw
it out of a bucket
the franklin was like yeah that was my
ex that was my hand
[Laughter]
your ex was like
[Laughter]
this rodney dangerfield side of you is
great
i got no respect
i really i really do
hate it though when when animals get
[ __ ] killed when they're already
suffering in enclosed spaces it's [ __ ]
it is but someone [ __ ] with them dumb
ass human error is the result of like a
dead animal now and then he loses his
arm dude but there's no but because the
animals aren't you know able to
articulate themselves you never build
enough of an emotional connection to be
like wait a minute that guy was wrong
yeah it's just a dead animal and
everybody forgets it because there's
gonna be another dead enclosed animal in
like six months zookeeper when they
caught that dude with this arm
underneath the fence he should come and
push the rest of his body inside
oh no i can't help you whoops whoops
they're just like oh [ __ ] we don't have
to feed them today
get the pusher out here all right cause
that meat that they feed them is really
expensive so they can save a couple
bucks i blame them for why we can't
watch bears play basketball and ride
unicycles do i blame the grizzly man too
dude you ruined it all you ruined so
much of the branding for grizzly bears
yeah now they're seen as monsters
they're seen as like they'll eat you and
[ __ ] nonsense
we'll never see [ __ ]
elephants playing basketball and
dodgeball
and then people you know using them to
do the tricks like balance on one foot
did you guys ever go to a wrangling show
a ringling brother no kid yeah
that [ __ ] was mind-blowing to see an
elephant on a [ __ ] ball yeah that was
nuts that was banana and then you got to
ride the elephant i didn't write that i
didn't write the elephant you guys never
wrote it
elephants
wild are they really doing that [ __ ] out
of like terror
oh they're probably drugged up like the
ones in thailand
you know what i mean so they're like
docile i thought they were having a
blast dude i mean drugs are blast to
some people oh true you saw a monkey
little jeep
[ __ ] mother driving
he's driving a little jeep
[Music]
ah
[Music]